[Music]
after the more or less convincing remake
of The Lion King by this name the next
edition of a Disney classic has now been
confirmed
it's the 1955 released movie Lady and
the [ __ ]
which will be re-released as a
live-action film for Disney Plus while
in the Lion King people were thinking
that real animals were standing in front
of the camera in Lady and the [ __ ] this
will actually be the case in the story
of the Disney classic lady who belongs
to a noble family falls in love with the
straight [ __ ] and together the two of
them take on a mean dog catcher during
the course of the film whether or not
the new addition will stick to the
original movie or not isn't yet
officially decided behind the camera
there's also a decent speaker
constellation as Avengers thought Tessa
Thompson dubs lady and Justin through
from American Psycho [ __ ] for the more
sam elliott benedict wong and many more
will be heard the Lady and the [ __ ]
remake will be immediately available for
the u.s. launch of Disney Plus on
November 12 2009 tea despite the
unsuccessful release of soloist avoir
story there has been speculation for
some time that this never produce
another Star Wars series for its
streaming service Disney Plus you could
already read in February on the internet
platform Star Wars news net that Luke's
mentor obi-wan Kenobi is most likely to
be considered for it and now it is
finally official there will be a serious
with Evan McGregor in his role as Jedi
Master obi-wan Kenobi the exact plot of
the series isn't known yet but due to
the edge of McGregor it's assumed that
the series will be set between Revenge
of the Sith and a new hope and exact
release date is not known but the star
series the Mandalorian will be released
on November 12th on Disney Plus and the
last film of the skywalker saga the rise
of skywalker will be released on
december 18th in the cinemas Quentin
Tarantino's ninth film Once Upon a Time
in Hollywood has been shown in u.s.
cinemas for three weeks since he has
often announced that after 10 films it
will be over many fans are curious to
know what the culmination and last film
of Tarantino will be currently
considered a Django slash sorrow and
star trek but also Kill Bill 3 in the
podcast Tarantino also revealed that if
his 10th film was to be made from one of
his other films it would be a third kill
bill the
steadman also boosts the fact that he
spoke to lead actress
uma Thurman who was very pleased with
the idea unfortunately there is no
production started yet the Chinese film
industry has been booming for years no
wonder that even draw famous Hollywood
blockbusters are used as role models for
in-house productions currently all three
films of the upcoming Fangshan trilogy
are being shot which are heavily based
on Lord of the Rings in an interview
with Variety the director explains that
they want to combine Lord of the Rings
and Iron Man but that's not all as to
Feng Shang trilogy will be the beginning
of a gigantic franchise and will include
an elaborate schedule for the next 30
years director Wu Shan makes no secret
out of the fact that they clearly
orientate himself on the MCU because he
wants to use the Marvel Universe method
to get deeper into each character the
movies are also quite expensive as the
budget for function is set at incredible
445 million u.s. dollars in terms of
content Feng Shang will also be based on
the Chinese literary classic creation of
God from the 16th century in which
elements from history mythology and
folklore are mixed it will be exciting
to see whether the producers plan works
out and whether fangshan marks the
beginning of a great era the release
date is supposed to be 2022 and it is
said that Disney and function are
already talking about international
marketing rights it's common practice at
the cinema to turn off your cell phone
an idea of Aleksandra al-jihad ever now
plans to see the cinema hall as an
interactive stage and to be able to
access the screen with a mobile phone
the collider reports that the crawl
director is currently preparing for a
still nameless interactive haunted house
horror film Steven Spielberg's
production company Amblin partners will
then take over the realization of the
film project the screenplay will be
written by Nick Simon and led by the
spookin Hill House creators Jeff Howard
and Mike Flanagan the interactive method
which is strongly reminiscent of
Bandersnatch is to be called control
movie technology and allows the viewer
to make groundbreaking decisions in the
film itself thus the film can also have
different running times and ends the
decision making is made there by
democratically after the majority
principle definitely an exciting idea
which already exists in homes in
when the production starts is known yet
though on 6th of September chapter 2 of
it will be released in the cinemas
director and the muschietti provides
fans with the eagerly awaited sequel to
his celebrated adaption of the Stephen
King novel after that he continues as a
director of the comic version of the
flash and the past apocalyptic film the
electric state but as a producer he will
remain faithful to Stephen King since he
and his sister Barbara muschietti have
been working on the next adaption for a
long time the King novel wrote work
published in 1981 under an alias is
supposed to serve as a model for a
fantastic script
however the muskie at least don't want
to take too much time yes the shooting
is supposed to start at the beginning of
next year road work is about Barton
George Dawes who runs a laundry in his
house however when he is told that his
house and thus his last existence is to
be demolished due to a motorway
construction doors arms himself in his
house and slowly but surely falls into
madness with the start of shooting next
year a release at the end of 2020 or
2024 is likely
[Music]